Okay,
should be live here. Hello.
right,
I think that's good.
There it goes.
Okay,
I finished. I'm going to say what is a
95% confidence ablation,
which is good enough for me to act on
that. We no longer need prioritized
replay.
This was semiexpected
from um the 40 update.
Prioritize replay becomes much weaker
now that we have
long horizon bootstrap
prioritize replay becomes much weaker.
I'm trying to think if there's any
possible way that this gets messed up.
I don't think so.
It's possible that we end up cutting
this
and um
we want to put some form of it back, I
suppose.
I think that the version that we would
put back in either event would be much
simpler.
Yeah, I think that any version we put
back would be much simpler
and would have
maybe one hyper at most.
It will be worth playing with that at
some point, [clears throat]
but I think for now we're fine. I think
we're going to do the simple thing.
We're not going to creep any more stuff
into this release.
Let me actually check when was the 40
release date.
How have I done on terms of time?
This is April.
So May, June, July, August. Oh yeah,
it's been four months.
That's good enough. I think we are.
Yeah, we are happy. I don't need any of
these tabs. Close all this. We're good.
Good morning, folks.
Good morning.
Okay, so here's what we're going to do.
We're going to remove prioritized replay
from the stack.
Don't need this. Don't need this. Do
need this.
Hey, convert. Yep. This is all weekend
stream.
I am going to split it up into chunks.
So, I'm going to do 2 three hours now.
Take an hour for breakfast.
But we're going to be doing a lot of
stream this weekend.
[sighs]
I did that in college. We're not ever
doing that [ __ ] again.
Okay, cool.
I think that will both be a cool and a
useful learning experience for you as
well.
YouTube isn't working on reream again.
Seriously,
You mean the chat's not working?
Oh, yeah. The chat's not working. Okay.
I'll try to keep both chats up if I can.
Um, that's that's kind of on reream for
being bad, but
liking Grock. Same as 45 as far as I can
tell.
Nice to have it though.
I'm glad they didn't make it slow.
It seems like it's still fast.
this is uh the pre-release weekend. That
doesn't mean we're releasing next week,
by the way. It just means that we're
going to have a stable version um by
next week. You know,
there's still a bunch of like release
work to be done that's not dev, but um I
think in terms of like all the features
and stuff, it's all there. Just have
some Yeah, the beta will be up. It'll be
merged into the official 5 branch
instead of this 5C.
And it'll be considered like feature
complete
while feature complete subject to bug
fixes. This
I'll go work with high sample reuse. Uh
that's what I've been doing for the last
like week. Jess, it turns out that like
basically everything was broken and
while I was being somewhat stupid, like
the rest of the field was being even
more stupid. Impala straight up does not
work. Um, which is that's like a top 10
paper in the field that does not work.
Uh, my theoretical result merging V
trace and J holds perfectly. The reason
it doesn't work is because impala just
does not work. It's not any problem with
the theoretical result or how I did it
or anything. I tried all possible
combinations. Um the good news is we
actually get to simplify the stack and
delete five hypers versus puffer 4 and
we get better performance. We actually
soda.
No, I am going to keep vrace. I'm going
to keep vrace implemented because the
theoretical result is so cool. Um,
however, it is going to be off by
default and not included in the default
sweep parameters.
The problem with Impala, it was a grabag
of different techniques.
And um
when people say they use like the Impala
algorithm or whatever, they're kind of
like referring to one portion or another
of that grab bag. But the actually only
major algorithmic change that they made
does not work like confirmed does not
work.
It does not work generally. It does not
work in the setting that they described.
It does not work anywhere. And by does
not work I don't mean that the original
results were fabricated or anything. I
mean that their baseline was very weak
and it does not provide any sort of lift
over a um a strong baseline.
and it actually typically makes your
results worse.
So, we had a bug where vrace was never
actually enabled in the first place. So,
it's equivalent, but we do get to cut
hypers out of the sweep.
Less confusing for um protein
This is a quick experiment for
reference. And then we're going to
strip. Basically, what we're going to do
is we're going to strip out prior
replay.
We might end up putting a weaker form of
it back into uh six, by the way. But I'm
not committing to fully like that this
technique is never good. But um I think
that the version that we have of it
definitely not worth.
We also have soda on um 2048 by quite a
good margin.
Did we have maze? Actually,
hang on. Let's close this.
Let's go check maze.
And I love constellation so much that I
just have my previous version results on
the browser like this.
It's super nice, honestly.
in like 10 minutes. Okay, look at that.
Uh uptime. There we go. 0.993
was the highest that we got. So, we do
actually have soda
across two of our major tasks.
B trace plus sweep. Uh, okay. I already
answered that.
That's very nice.
This matches existing soda perfectly,
but I'm sure that we had higher than
this.
Oh, hey Liberty. Sorry, it's I have two
windows of chats up. Okay, I have to
notice both of them. Is it true that
Jurgen? Yeah, Schmidt Huber invented
Puffer a long time ago
if you think about it.
I have to manually have the YouTube chat
open today because reream doesn't do
things for some reason.
I'd love to not be linked to reream, but
I haven't found an alternative.
Yeah, pryo actually hurts now.
It's probably hard to find because uh
the sweep space that I specified is
good. 5 minutes for this. This is fine.
This is the last experiment we're going
to have to run for a while and then it's
just all going to be editing because
we're just going to strip out prioritize
replay. We're going to strip out all the
extra crap. We're going to get Puffer to
about 9.5K lines, I believe. Eight
files, 9.5K lines,
and then we will just be able to like
start messing with stuff. After a
certain time, it connects automatically.
Well, it hasn't yet, and I've been live
for a while, so me.
That means that we're consistently
solving um the biggest mazes cleanly.
That will look physic like that will
look very different when we go to run
the policies.
YouTube chat doesn't appear in stream.
Go yell at reream.
I did not change anything with the
settings whatsoever. Reream sometimes
just decides to not work.
I have it open on the side, but I
occasionally miss stuff because I have
to have two chats open.
This will be done in a couple minutes is
fine. And then we will um we'll
basically just be able to strip this
Early stream. Yeah. I'm doing all
weekend, man. Pretty much all weekend
stream.
I'm going to split it up a little bit.
So, I'm going to do two, three hours
now. Breakfast, whole bunch of hours,
dinner. Probably more hours after
dinner. We'll see.
Just got stuck.
Dumb.
99.9.
Very nice.
Perfect. 99.94
up from 99.3.
If it's just like a video about RL.
Yeah, sure.
You're not doing anything sketchy with
it.
I generally don't care if people use
clips of mine and stuff as long as
they're not using them for sketchy stuff
or like promote whatever.
If you just want to use the You can use
the rage bait clips if you want, I
guess.
I'm sure that was uh oh whatever.
The trick to being able to live stream
all this dev is you cannot hold yourself
to like professional working standards
on stream. You basically just hold
yourself to whatever Discord standard
because otherwise it would be
exhausting, right? Like I'm not going to
be here like ah yes, you know,
professional mode on my live stream.
This is like chill and work
and uh this will be much more active in
a second here.
There's basically just a bunch of AI
like just LM experiment scaffolding that
needs to be deleted and then uh I can
tighten up a bunch of the code around
that. But I it needs to just go first.
Yeah, the hedge funds and stuff like
finance will do that in
I've told people not to like ask me for
traditional interview advice because
it's kind of you just have to grind a
bunch of [ __ ] puzzles.
>> [laughter]
>> H.
Not really, but there's more of it.
That's funny.
Yeah, he's the funny guy. Anytime
anybody like posts something about
billionaires being bad as well, he like
he replies, "Oh, but I made Minecraft."
And they say, "All right, you're cool."
[laughter]
But you just think that's so funny that
he bothers replying to that stuff.
I'm going to know roughly by the code
length immediately whether this is
[ __ ] But then um we'll also just be
able to
diff it versus the 10k.
I they I saw they released something. I
didn't see actually what it This
Yeah, that's a nice bit of code to get
rid of.
That's a very nice bit of code to get
Couple 100 lines.
The pryo kernels were especially
annoying to me because it's a very
simple operation, but just the kernels
for it are just a mess.
This actually will make puffer a little
bit faster as well, which is nice.
GPU duck.
Oh, it was like the Yeah, you just plug
a GPU into whatever thing.
That's fun.
I don't really have a use for that, but
cool.
I mean, the main thing I have a use for
is just like good, stable
5090 boxes at a price that's not
ludicrous.
Yeah, but when you subtract something
small from something that is already
small, it matters.
Even Joseph uses AI to code. It's
actually using AI to delete code. If you
can see what's happening here,
this isn't just deleting code. in fact.
And I don't know what it's doing here,
but this is probably getting removed as
well. Yeah, this is doing some [ __ ]
random sampling that I want to get rid
of most likely.
robot arm.
Cool. If you do it to 5C, I can get it
merged in probably even today.
No, that's fine, right?
That's fine.
Yeah, the EMA rewards. This can get just
removed.
9.8K.
I think it can get to 9.5.
Let's get rid of this infinity path.
Hello, welcome
2D games.
Uh, Anish, currently our best benchmark
that I like trust the most for our
research
is this game right here.
This is literally the best benchmark we
have for research.
So
the things that are useful are not
always the things that you would expect.
Tasks that just scale really hard are
often quite useful because they let us
test like the low end and the high end
of our training.
Haven't watched Dream since 4.0? What
are you doing now? This is working on
the 5.0 no pre-release,
which is going to be about 9.5,000,
maybe up to 10K, but definitely under
10K lines of code for all of 50. Uh up
to 2.5x faster compared to Puffer 4 and
a small uh small little state-of-the-art
improvement, I'd say overall as well.
Small ALGO improvement to
state-of-the-art
goal of today is first of all going to
be to clean up and delete all the extra
crap that we have in here that we don't
need. Um, that's just going to be
probably the first chunk of the stream
today before I take a break for
breakfast. And then after that, it's
probably going to just be testing out
all the features, making any last like
cleanup decisions on um usage, getting
all the ends in.
Thank you very much. I will I'll get the
robot arm in as well.
You do have to think a little bit
though. definition like
I know what types of tasks do you think
are easy to write down um and easy to
solve at some base level but could scale
really hard like so is another task that
we have that I really really like
that's going to be a major benchmark for
us
how much code is adding for this [ __ ]
okay not bad.
I do want to run this ablation real
quick.
5 minutes to run. It's not bad.
Selfplay and sparse reward stuff active
and um being merged into puffer 5. Well,
actually, hang on. Those are two
different things. So, selfplay active
ported fully to cudc being merged into
puffer 5 and Spencer has been working on
robo code and working on core research
on that while I've been doing other core
50 stuff. Um, the sparse reward state
set stuff is getting switched to puffer
6 in favor of more selfplay as well as
the end toend cuda to end optim
optimizations going into puffer 5.
It's really just it's not worth it
anymore. Like pietorrch is so much
slower. Their numeric suck. it like
causes a ton of dependency issues.
Puffer is now just about the simplest
thing ever. You just grab yourself um
any machine that has a full CUDA setup.
Nvidia's like CUDA dev Docker will be
perfectly suitable. Um super compact and
small download container gets smaller,
dep
way way way less locked to any
particular version of CUDA. So you
actually get better hardware support out
of this. It's just better.
And if you're worried about complexity,
fear not. I just spent like weeks
getting puffer to be super compact. So,
selfplay uh constellation
the whole protein sweep algorithm from
glitzy everything in here is under 10k
lines and that includes 600 uh 1,600
lines for constellation 500 lines for
any file support
uh proteins 1,200 the CPU eval
so look at this the actual code for
puffer
is 5k lines
I'll go plus puffer. This is the entire
source. 5k lines.
Isn't that crazy?
Gym compatible M's like Majoko.
Um, with Python binds, nope. But any of
the ones that have like low-level C++ or
whatever, you can just bind them into
Puffer at that level, right? Just don't
use the gym package. like you want to do
Atara, you want to do procgen, you want
to do like any of the uh the warp
backend stuff, just bind it to bind it
to RC. You can bind C or C++ or Rust or
any other low-level language uh that can
integrate with C. You can bind directly.
And that is right. Thank you, Anes. You
can uh you can support all this stuff
for free just by starting the puffer on
GitHub. That is true. A true statement.
I basically I see no path forward that
involves like slow Python in the loop
for RL. There's basically no world in
which it makes sense to be doing RL and
spending time and effort on ends that
run like 500 SPS.
Anything that's written native in Python
is relatively straightforward to port
over to see. Typically, Python projects
don't get to be too big in the first
place. Anything that is a Python wrapper
over low-level code, it's typically very
easy to just like delete the wrapper
portion and do that and see
We do support C++ now natively as well
through um in VCC.
So RMs when we take PRs we typically
require that everything be Oh Jesus,
look at this.
Um yeah, we typically require our NPRs
to be C99 compatible.
Um but generally since we switched to
just one compilation unit in NVCC you
can do C++ ends and even CUDA ends
Also, the funniest thing um about the
Puffer 4 release is we kind of just
dropped all of the random Python
environments that we used to support and
nobody noticed. So, like literally
nobody was using that crap.
didn't say anything. Okay, a few people
noticed.
We should actually have Atari and
procgen.
That's super easy to get binds for
though.
fix the vector API for 1.5 years.
Yeah, there's just there's no way to fix
it, man. Like, you just can't have that.
You cannot have Python in the loop like
that uh in the end loop and have stuff
be fast. It will eventually bottleneck
you. And like for the people saying,
"Oh, but it's not the bottleneck in our
code." Yeah, well that's cuz the rest of
your code is slow.
Like yes, I you see me optimizing things
that nobody else remotely cares to
optimize, but that's because everything
is fast. And when everything is fast,
like you get a flat profile where
everything is the bottleneck and
individual microsconds matter.
Heck, nanconds matter in some of our
very hot loops.
bouncing dot chart.
That was funny.
very late to reply. So solution has been
get rid of impala.
Um I mean we get rid of vrace
like we keep it in the code to be fair
because it's two lines and it's a really
cool theoretical result. Um, so you can
play with it and in fact I'll invite
anybody who thinks they can make vrace
work like give it a try in our codebase.
Um, but we actually can remove vrace
prioritize sampling. We had an extra
optimizer parameter or two that was not
being used.
So,
This thing is still going, by the way.
And that's not even our best policy
anymore.
I do hope we end up training one that's
like a a small policy that's still
pretty good.
9.84 uh 9.8K. Really? Uh this puffer net
file, this LM did this crap. We'll
delete this in a second. So, one, two,
three, four. Yeah, it's still eight
files.
60go.
No, 6 was planning. We were planning to
replace prioritize sampling with um 6o
anyways. It's a much stronger form. Um,
it's just that the pryo sampling, it
turns out because of the architecture
changes and the longer horizon
bootstrap, pryiosampling is just weak
enough that it doesn't matter anymore
and it's essentially just confusing
protein at this point. So, it's better
to remove it.
You also will get a small PF boost back
from uh removing it because you uh you
get to sample from contiguous memory.
It's pretty nice. In fact, we're going
to have to tighten a couple kernels
today to account for that.
engineering sim trick that actually
makes it fast. Bottleneck of running
simulation is there tons of things you
can do in sim engineering to make stuff
faster. Um, it depends how optimized
your thing is to begin with. Like most
problems that I look at like they just
have not been designed remotely
correctly at all. And anything that I
can do, like anything I do will make it
much faster. For stuff that's already
pretty well optimized, you end up just
going and looking for corners you can
cut, like fidelity that you can drop
that doesn't actually affect the uh the
quality of the policies. And then you
experiment with that in a loop.
result from sweep. Ooh,
we also we have soda with a simple we
have soda with minus five
hyperparameters and much simpler code.
Any fun RL party tricks?
Oh, yeah.
Uh, I mean, training stuff like
instantaneously is a pretty good one.
Here,
let's train a breakout agent. Oops, it's
done.
Uh, Spencer, there's a pretty big
difference in steps there.
I noticed that
held out might just take longer to
learn.
But if if that doesn't if that's not the
case, then yeah, that's very
interesting, huh?
Marine ad from Twitch.
Yeah.
messing with Gigabatch
found better perf. This is sweep v
sweep.
Yeah, I that is very weird, man.
Um,
I'm trying to think what we can do with
that.
Wait, but you didn't just run pure
selfplay yet, did you?
this pure scaled selfplay stuff.
That was one that was one of the major
things, right?
Though it's uh and by pure scaled would
be historical selfplay obviously
scaled historical selfplay
ongoing 100 bill. Cool.
We we could even put it in more
contiguous memory. I suppose
25 bell for faster test. Yeah,
that's fair.
I mean, we have the scaling theory,
right?
The question is going to be, do you get
something that is significantly better
out of just scaling the crap out of it
than you did um than you could get with
just the pure selfplay before, right?
I'm just having it time something real
quick and then we're going to fix this
because this looks like a mess to me.
I've wanted to have this um in
contiguous me for a long time.
Bro, you're not Why are you writing a
benchmark?
Stupid thing.
It just I didn't ask it to do this.
Smart thing to do would have been to run
um
uh kernel profile on the full fun.
Oops.
Hang on one second.
All right.
Just had to deal with something.
Oh, I bet it I I bet I know what it did.
I bet it did something completely
stupid.
I think they're actually smaller at the
moment inish, but I'm super lean, so it
looks proportionally better. This is the
lightest I've been in a while. I've
basically just been starving myself all
summer. Uh, I'm at 171 pounds.
I get like a bagel sandwich and two
bowls of soup per day and that's all I
eat.
recipe. I I don't cook, dude. It's
literally I just There's um there's like
a bakery slash deli type place where I
get like an egg sandwich with a bagel
and some vegetables. They also have
minestrone soup. So, I have some
vegetable soup basically and then I go
get a big bowl of chicken soup for
dinner at a Mexican place. A lot of the
What end is this?
Oh. Um, we use Robo Code for, uh, our
own selfplay testing now because it's
fast. It's pretty good.
But what we would have to have it all
contiguous. Yes.
I think we can.
Yeah. Yeah. So, it's this is this was
one kernel before, but the key insight
is not this. The key insight is going to
be that we can graph the whole train and
then not need this at all. Whereas we
would need this copy before,
we don't need this copy at all now.
It'll be a nice big uh speed up.
And the puffer just gets faster. I don't
know what to tell you. The puffer just
gets faster and faster.
full EPO graph just not remove the copy.
Okay.
It did actually figure this out by the
way from the uh the first thing. So it
this it is a little There.
by any of the definitions that were
floated around. Um,
way way way back when before people
tried to like move the goalpost towards
them so that they could claim it.
What?
That's so weird.
All right.
Yeah, stay weird, RLC.
I am I'm not going this year. I figure
that I'm going to RLC is this weekend.
I'm instead going to stay here and
stream all weekend and do the
pre-release.
If I'd actually lined it up better, I
should have released it for RLC. Say,
They've added a comma. Don't care. It's
fine.
This is something I've wanted to have
for a while, which is fully graph
training.
It's actually should not take any longer
to trace than normal, should it?
No,
cuz it reuses Yeah, it reuses the
buffers.
This might actually be a significant
speed up to be honest with you.
Let's see three.
It depends how many micros seconds we're
assuming the graph launches.
thousands will be
eh we'll see if it's small or not.
I'm hoping it's just rearranging my
existing code here.
What the hell?
Oh,
We'll get this to work. Just take a
second.
I mean to register pressure from params,
dude. It has to do more operations.
It like literally has to do four times
more ops.
If anything, I'm pretty sure it's the um
the mem pressure of um the doubled
activation sizes,
We'll get this swept though.
Let me make sure that we can actually
get this to be faster than 50 mil first.
It just leaked. I just saw that it just
leaked in uh it just leaked instructions
like never mention something or either.
Did you see that?
It just leaked uh whatever the heck it's
like it system prompt is. Oh, I'm sorry.
Also, I didn't have the the YouTube up
chat for a while.
Oh, but the YouTube chat's working now,
so it's fine.
So, we're going to get 50 mil SPS with
the 950MS on the original config here.
And then we are going to
get it a little faster ideally with um
cudigraphs over the whole train.
Wonder if we could cudigraph the whole
end.
How the hell does that guy have time to
be rank one Diablo in hardcore?
Epo graph looks to be a small
small difference which is fine.
He hired some dude.
I don't know. Oh, there have been
multiple reports from people close to
him that like he actually just plays the
thing a ridiculous amount. on.
This is where I reveal that I've been
the one leveling his account all this
time. No,
I have my own account to level. Thank
you very much. Side monitor content.
what do you do when you max everything?
It's literally the meme of like, now you
play the game.
I played WoW actually for a couple weeks
on a a vacation not that long ago, like
last year or whatever, and I got bored
of it very quickly.
I thought it had like very long-term
progression, but it's basically like a
seasonal
it's like a seasonal dungeon game at
this point.
Not it's not really like the long form
of an MMO anymore.
Even as a new player, like leveling
takes a couple days.
I thought that was a meme like, "Oh
yeah, it takes a couple days like if you
know exactly how to do everything and
have unlimited money or whatever." I
played games like that before where it
takes three months. No, it takes longer.
It actually takes a year if you're a new
player and it literally takes a day if
you have all the stuff to do it
correctly.
I don't know. I've played that game like
once in a while and like, yeah, it's
fun, but I really just um
it's the type of thing where there's
always like, you know, I'm not really in
the mood to play,
like a competitive thing, and I just
like something chill that I can do on
the side for a bit. And uh, you know, RS
always has that. Like MMOs just always
have something for whatever state you're
Man,
goal is to just make it really really
fast right now. And um
then we'll re sweep for score
farming route.
Oh, it can learn something like that
super easily. Like a few minute loop.
Yeah, that's super easy for it to learn.
It can already do stuff way more
complicated than that.
Not shuffling data
slightly sketchy,
the heck is single player?
Um,
it's not really. It's kind of just like
mother of all rogue likes. Uh, yeah,
rogue likes. It kind of
is the rogue game.
We're close to it.
Mingru's been like had fused basically
everything for um since 40.
This what I'm doing here. This is for uh
the train loop. This is basically just
cutting some of the fluff off that we
had for prioritize sampling.
Finalizing Inferno and Ko this weekend.
VA, we're also finalizing our uh our
like 50 build pretty much this weekend.
Puffer demos on Instagram.
Hey, Star the Puffer on GitHub. It helps
us out a lot. It's all free.
We do have professional services, but
those are uh not targeted at hobbyists
or academics or whatever. So, those are
just for big companies that are doing
fancy RL and want some help.
Yeah, we have we're basically doubling
the number of environments here with all
the new ones being merged in.
Um 50 is going to be by design a smaller
update than 40. But I think what 50 does
is it removes all of the growing pains
that we have from going to CUDA in 40 by
like fully committing to it and
stripping out all of the old Python and
dependencies and jank.
Use gem and gate.
I think the only way you could remotely
do that would be with um
custom epilog or something or by having
your own entire map mole.
It would be nice to have. It really
would be nice to have.
I think that would give us a substantial
beat up as well.
But I don't know if there's a reasonable
way to do That
Okay, cool. You slowed it down. Nice
job.
Inferno's 2.1 mil.
Not bad. Not getting wins though.
I highly doubt that the puffer five algo
changes will make it win. It's pretty
minor on the algo side.
We do have a few improvements to be
fair, but I doubt it like totally fixes
any new problems.
graph be nicer.
We can also Can we cudigraph the end?
Maybe we can.
We'll probably have some time to like
make some silly demos honestly once this
is fully set up.
I don't know what this is doing here.
We'll uh we'll fix that. I I think
that's redundant.
Hey, let's say
welcome to uh
our current
fix everything as fast as possible
session.
We have soda overnight on 2048 with a
very very simple stack.
No prioritize replay, no advantage
normalization.
We're now just going to get stuff as
fast as possible.
no ads norm is kind of crazy. Um, it's
not though because Muan
admittedly it is. I will admit the
squared error term
can be kind of sketchy,
but
it works. And we've swept both maze and
um 2048 to soda without ed of norm
faster for me up to H6. Right. But the
thing is, dude, you can't just replace
our matmo with a custom one that's like
faster up to hidden 64. That's not
helpful.
In fact, I think what we're going to do
is after 50, we're going to stop
targeting networks uh below 100k
parameters for our optimizations
because you get like ridiculous [ __ ]
otherwise.
Like, isn't this just a naive maple
or is there some tiling [ __ ] in here?
Oh, no. You actually do have tiling.
Okay.
Yeah. But like still you can't just do
this right where you put in your
uh your Mattal kernel if it's going to
underperform Kublast
at larger sizes.
was the snake config.
Uh the thing that was useful for that
config was that now I know that I don't
need to oneh hot the obs to get 125
score.
So yes, I did need that. Thank you. And
that's going to be uh the whole like fix
all the ends section of the workday is
going to be after we figure out this
current mess.
Well, no, we don't actually, right? It's
like 2 ms for the first epoch. Okay.
That's fine.
Actually, I'm fine with that. It's one.
This is a rounding error.
I don't know if that'll actually do
anything. We'll see. It might just go
super fast.
So I checked with and without advantage
norm. It didn't even shift the hyper
parameters by the way for 2048. Like you
basically got the same score with or
without advantage norm on the same
hypers and it soda. So
um I think that Muan just absorbs that
with its orthogonalization.
Muan's doing a lot of the work here for
us.
Wasn't sure if it could be extended. I'm
It's just about evaluating performance
at different points on the curve, right?
like very roughly we care about networks
in the 100k to 10 million parameter
range though uh the high end of that
should be like we should be relatively
efficient and our stack should not break
if we do 100 mil either
above 100 mil I'm happy having to
redesign some stuff but 100 mil we can
solve a lot of problems with
That's funny.
That's kind of funny that that works.
Yeah, that's funny.
How much code did that just add?
Almost nothing.
Does not look good. We do have to make
sure we didn't break training somehow
with any of this.
I just need to make sure we didn't break
training.
this sweep.
I think it's broken. So, I'll let this
do this.
What time is it?
10:30. I think now is a good time for me
to get breakfast or in a minute or two
here.
So, I'm going to go order breakfast
and then I'll go walk to pick it up
uh after we set this up. I'm going to
just basically have this thing figure
out what the regression is in the
meantime. And then uh once we have it
cleaned, I will come back. I will
manually clean up all of the code. Um
it's not that much. It's like maybe two
300 lines worth of changes. If I can
clean that up and then we'll do all the
M stuff in the second session today.
Even stuff like the uh the cudigraph on
first uh first epoch like that was very
difficult to get Okay.
seven. And now this this is you see it's
the same.
Um but it should learn to not run long
experiments. This one still might be
10.1.
Okay. Okay. But it's now it should be
like not running long stuff. I would
hope
uh maybe
maybe or maybe it's still running long
stuff. Either way, I think what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go grab uh
my breakfast
and then we're going to come back. We're
going to diagnose if there's an issue
here. We'll figure it out. Hopefully, we
come back to this thing just having
found us like a new stable sub one
second solve.
And it was just hypers. We'll see. And
then we will clean up this code. Uh
we'll get this pushed and we will
basically just go through all of the
different ends and make improvements. I
still have this 8GPU box available and
what we're going to use it for today.
Okay, I left it running a sweep
overnight, but then I didn't kill it
this morning because I'm basically going
to set this 8GPU box up um with access
to my local machine or vice versa. And
we're going to just have it run all of
the baselines for all of the ends in a
loop while I essentially go through and
test everything and make sure stuff is
working. So, uh for everybody who's new
around here, I'll be back in probably a
little under an hour. Just got to go
grab my breakfast. Um start puffer on
GitHub.
Everything's free and open source.
Everything is at puffer.ai.
And I will be streaming
pre-release work all weekend. We're
going to aim for like a nice sub10k line
stable build of Puffer with all the
different benchmarks cleaned up, um, all
the different demos working cleanly,
etc., etc. So, that sounds interesting.
You can tune back in. Thank you.